nähme jahr dirigiert das detroit
symphony orchestra
paavo järvi sein ältester sohn führt das
orchestre de paris
christian lehr wie die regiert auf dem
werbefestival wie der vater so die söhne
auf der menuhin festival im staat leiht
nehmer und christian ja wie gemeinsam
eine conducting academy angehende
dirigenten können hier mit einem
professionellen orchester arbeiten dazu
mit christian und nehme ja wie als
lehrer eine der seltenen gelegenheiten
bei der sich die beiden weltreisenden
musiker nomaden sehr und so musste
dirigenten nachwuchs zugleich vater und
sohn als kritiker ertrag
ja
ok
nein nein stopp statt
das ist langweilig
außen hinein mach es dynamischer lass
mich manchmal möchte ich auch dirigieren
christian lernte klassische musik kenne
noch bevor er sprechen konnte mozart war
bei aris allgegenwärtig die musik kam
aus einer schrankwand mit riesigen
lautsprechern und die vielen auf mich
plötzlich hörte ich ein poltern und er
fing an zu weinen und kam in die küche
und beklagte sich bitterlich über mozart
dass man das erste wort in seinem leben
mozart hatte mich geschlagen ich wusste
nicht was ein lautsprecher ist ich
dachte das denn dass mir auf den kopf
fiel sei mozart auf diese weise haben
wir den kindern musik näher gebracht
weniger schmerzlich die begegnung mit
jazz in den 80er jahren die avis
emigrierten in die usa
christian war ein teenager in der
klassischen musik haben wir auch
swinging in amerika ist das sehr populär
du musst zwingen
darin ist christian stark er ist ein
guter jazzmusik und deshalb kann er das
auch gut bei klassischer musik
es scheint als sei die musik eine art
geheimsprache ein unsichtbarer faden
zwischen vater und sohn
seine liebe zur musik ist richtig
ansteckend
wann immer mich musiker eines orchesters
nach meinem vater fragen
erinnern sie sich wie großartig das war
selbst wenn das 30 jahre ist sie
erinnern sich nicht weil er einen großen
namen hat sondern wie er das ganze
orchester mitgerissen hat mit seiner
liebe zur musik und ich denke das hat er
auch bei uns kindern geschafft auch
politik astronomie und philosophie
hatten christian interessiert doch
letztlich übertrug sich die väterliche
begeisterung für musik auch auf ihn
freiwillig wie er betont
in einer hinsicht war meine eltern nicht
erfolgreich mich zu irgendetwas zu
drängen
da war kein zwang
schon es aber auch weniger emotionen
schlanker ja ja
jetzt los
tempo tempo
diese geballte ladung ansteckender
begeisterung für musik soll sich an der
conducting akademie auch auf die
nachwuchs dirigenten übertragen